in this capsule we will see the notion
of substitution so we are seen
previously only to make a prep
resolution need some tools
too much that we will need the
substitution
so that's what we will see in this
capsule i'm going to start by defining
some terms
firstly the notion of literal
so a bed land that will match
to a Wallinian predicate in the negation
of a body loan so the predicted cope
a case xy or the country negation xy you
both make shorelines to those
of his going to define the notion of klose a
clause will correspond to a disjunction
of several liberals for example if
I had the literal country xy of 2 xyz
t1 or the negation of peace 1x z
but if I do disjunction everything
that would be what's called a clause
so now a substitution is going
to be a set that predicts so a
set of fathers of the form xxi equal
country where fingers is a variable
was hyper more generally a
term it will have to be synonymous only in
the set all the xy are distinct
which they correspond to variables
be different here is an example of a
substitution the set of x and galls
john and y equals father of the constant
town hall so we notice here that right
we can have a more complicated term
as a function involves at a
constant sahara even could be a
variable if we could have had another
variable will give way to town hall or
performers simply a
constant and the substitution is going
actually correspond to an operation
would change all the values ​​of x for
the variables that are integrating them into
term that is sometimes involved
so as I have a die the application
a substitution will we note here
head to an alpha literal is so there
this laval app has rated alpha
head to your correspond to take alpha
then to replace all
the occurrences of variables etc if by
their term to society i in the
substitution and we will do that for
each of the fathers of substitution xxi
equality there is we will say that al fath and
so that's the result of
the application of the substitution will be
an instance of alpha for the
substituting ths states for example its
notice the following literal and xy f1 and
that we had the substitution ths state that
says who is replaced by x and x by b
and apply the solution teta a
littoral
alpha would correspond to take by name
excluded replaced by b here we would get
this part there too and then take the
variable y is replaced by the term x
would go there would be replaced by x to mark
and that it is not him replaced this
after by have made an Arabic the
simultaneous seed so in parallel
for each of the arguments of the predicted
that in and finally fpa not charge him
since it can involve in the
substitution
so that's for a loner in
now his pen c is fine
applied a substitution amazes you klaus
and where macro sea corresponds to
the addition of a term
alpha 1 to alpha n2 literals
forgiveness while it brakes well the
clause resulting from the application of
head has enough your the addition of
each of the eight heroes we have
applied the substitution maybe we
was going to nerdy nerds or a us site
up to al fahem head
we can compose together several
substitution so let's imagine that
state institutions that involves
variables x1 up to excellent and a
sigma substitution that involves
variables y 1 to ym
we might want to apply step
is then applied sigma so that's it
is going to be a community composition head
in the cinema so mark that we add
all the time there after a literal one
clause we add on the right the
institutions that we wish to apply
in order now the composition
head to the sigma did we can calculate it
if we are given here the formula for head
to the form nothing is actually in
able to lead what is the whole
business substitutions in head to
sigma with a small procedure with the
three next steps
so we'll see the next three steps
to know an example then we start
to build the whole by taking
two heads to all of these variables
x so we extracted here until xx
and the term associated in fact we're going
take the term s then we want him
apply the sigma substitution which is
the second source is also our
our composition
so we do that for and 5 against what
we apply the association sigma then to
Saint-mont applies the competition six
month also
so this is the first part of my
together the second part it's going to be
outright substitution
sigma that I just tried then
meaning we will do what we want
delete all the pairs left there y
are such as years philippe legré who
corresponds to one of the variables in the
substitution head so 1d x there in the
substitution of time and finally one
will delete the identities ie
fathers or is it sinaï became
exactly excludes so forward with a
example cross-country look
turn it a lot more concrete then
imagine that we have the substitution ths
is to follow
to be applied followed by the
substitute sigma or dante is one to aix
who is replaced by f 2 yy who
replaced by z then dancing man x which
replaced by the constant at and then there is
replaced by the constant b as well as the
z replaced by a statement by the
variable forgiveness y first step on
take sigma we insert according to the new
substitution set and apply
in his words
so we have the first term icipe the
second term here we will apply the
sigma substitution are doing that gets
the next thing so became b
as specified in sigma then aix is
become there forgiveness z became that you
have substituted by y
so if we had said before we are
rendered with y who added in the
rest of the set exactly the
substituting for pigments then of that
what we do is we look
among the variables involved in the
second part of my composition so
that the variables of the
singbo substitution which are already
in the part that comes from head
when if we find x who finds himself
already here we find there who finds himself
already here then just the bars and
so remove them from our times his
third step
we identify who are the fathers who
match invariably affected or
substitute by itself
this is the case here then you simply
that once remove it and so the
result it's going to be the fathers that remains
to know and ségala f2b we have here then z
is equal to y who from here
finally some properties of
substitutions identity substitution
that we do not pound that corresponds to
all fast, that means doing
absolutely nothing is actually
identity since if I take a
trotot stone is a property if I
take a substitution ths state that I
compose it with the deletion
Belgian identity gets one more time
is it just the original solution
of state and so that's the equivalent of
do nothing next if I literally
to which I apply the sigma substitution
and that I'm going to take this and apply the
rite so the instance of that said he
the substitution head to ben is
the equivalent of actually taking sigma
theta compose them together then
finally take the result
apply it to montayral alpha so that
it's true for a literal but it's
also true in general for a clause and
finally if I had three
substitutions teta sigma also and
well compose the first two then
finally the third or dial the
last two and finally take the
result deal with the first that
give exactly the same solution
overall